- True or false, there are
ghosts in the White House?
- True.
- Ah, never going.
- True and listen, Kelly, you
would have liked these ghosts
'cause they were very musical.
They were musical and came with no harm.
They were kind, friendly,
compassionate ghosts.
So, Barbara and I were going to sleep,
our rooms were right next to each other
and it was in college when
people would call late.
So our phone rang and I
woke up and all of a sudden
we heard like 1920s piano music
coming out of our fireplace.
And I was like, surely that's
like the cat or something.
You know, we had to pretend,
but it was the middle of the night
and you could feel the
music out of the fireplace.
And I know, we tried to talk
ourselves out of it too.
like I can see you.
What do you think?
- Um, what I think is I
would have immediately
exited the premises. (laughs)
- We jumped into each other's beds.
- Oh.
- We were terrified,
but I'm telling you,
the ghosts were musical
and they came with no harm.
- I know, but--
- They weren't evil.
- You say 1920s piano music
and that is literally
like a horror film to me,
(audience laughs)
like late in the night,
like that kind of music is
like when you die, generally.
- Like jazz piano, jazz piano,
but I mean, you know you can't imagine
what's happened there, so I
think it was from another era,
but it was definitely terrifying.
- Oh my gosh.
Yeah, no, I'm good.
I've been there once.
I definitely won't be visiting again.